scientists like these at Oxford
University our new target for cyber
spies intelligence on coronavirus
vaccine programs is in high demand among
all countries but Britain and the United
States are accusing some of launching
cyberattacks
to try to steal the data they didn't
name names but the culprits are thought
to include hacking groups from China
Russia and Iran we have clear evidence
now that these criminal gangs are
actively targeting national and
international organizations which are
responding to the covert 19 pandemic
which I have to say makes them
particularly dangerous and venal at this
time we're absolutely determined to
defeat coronavirus and also to defeat
those trying to exploit the situation
for their own nefarious ends the
national cybersecurity center and its US
partner have issued a joint warning of
the threat they said targets include
medical research facilities
pharmaceutical firms even local
government workers are being advised to
improve password security to help fend
off attack the hacking threat is only
set to rise as countries race to find a
vaccine we really shouldn't be surprised
copy 19 is the top issue of our time and
every state is afflicted by the disease
so whoever is first to develop a vaccine
is going to win influence and power and
make a fortune the pandemic has already
inflamed tensions between the world's
two biggest powers the United States
accusing China of covering up the truth
about the virus Beijing saying
Washington is spouting disinformation
it's a criticism aimed at some UK MPs -
regrettably a few politicians in the UK
have been addicted to the Cold War
mentality the
compared China to the former Soviet
Union urge a review of China yoke a
relationship and even call for new Cold
War such talks a political barriers if
go unchecked they will poison China yoke
a joint effort the possibility of China
being a source of cyber attacks won't
calm its critics though it's thought
does not been a successful hack of a UK
healthcare target yet Deborah Haynes Sky
News